In the beginning of the 18th century,...
...Peter the Great had this idea to make a new capital for Russia,...
...and he wanted to make it right here, next to the Baltic Sea,...
...to have the window to Europe.
He was inspired by Amsterdam with its channels and he loved Holland so much,...
...and he wanted to use all of this European experience he had.
And his friends were telling him, and all the people around were telling that,...
..."You're crazy. You can't make a city here because it's a swamp."
Still, he built the city and it was 320 years ago.
I think Peter the Great probably was the most charismatic character in our history.
And even if we understand now that maybe he was so cruel...
...and maybe it was too much, the way he made all his reforms,...
...still, I think we love him and we respect the things he's done.